hey there viewers welcome back to my
spooky channel because it's Halloween
time and what better to do this October
then talk about the disgrace of the
Halloween Town franchise okay one of the
disgraces of the Halloween Town
franchise you know the one where Marnie
and then Marnie but instead she's
aquamarine from the movie aquamarine and
also Ryan from heist news achill is
there for some reason first and foremost
I would like to get something totally
stupid and nitpicky off my chest which
is that the way they've titled this
whole series really annoys me like the
first one is called Halloween town
obviously then for the sequel they went
for the whole colon method with
Halloween town to cooling and Calibre's
revenge so you'd think they'd want to
continue down that path and the third
one would be called Halloween town 3 :
bla bla bla and instead they just call
it Halloween town hi and they don't even
really stay consistent with that because
this one is called return to
Halloweentown like where's the
consistency where is the cohesiveness
why did they do this
this might single-handedly be why we
only claim the first two just kidding
there are a lot of reasons why we only
claim the first two I think there are a
couple of Disney Channel original movies
that transcend just being Disney Channel
Original Movies and Halloween town is
one of them it's basically just
Halloween town on high school musical
but you know you might remember from my
Disney Channel video that I think
sometimes people look back on nostalgic
properties with rose-colored glasses and
assume everything new has to be worse
just because it's new this is not one of
those cases like I watched the original
Halloween count for this video and it
still slaps to this day it might not be
winning any Oscars but it's cute and
funny enough that it's become a classic
Halloween movie we're trying to
Halloweentown is in my opinion in
arguably inferior and really stupid the
movie starts like this
of great Paulo would embrace the gift
Marnie Piper is a promo will of the
prophecy become cool so right from the
get-go any reasonable person would stop
watching because what is this but I had
a youtube video to make so I soldered on
and the next thing I saw was this map of
Halloweentown where they have completely
and conspicuously added which University
yeah that was not there before you can't
pull these tricks on me anyway which you
is where the movie takes place ever
trying to say out loud a little piece of
me dies I think cept that the witch
University I'm going to which you prom
well at which university I can't but I'm
really going to which University welcome
to which University so Marnie is having
this argument with her mom whose
character her by the way has essentially
been reduced to talking into household
objects hello mother are you alright
call it mothers intuition or which is
worried but because Marnie wants to go
to which you and her mom doesn't approve
sounds kind of familiar sounds kind of
like they took the beginning of the
first movie got rid of all the fun
dialogue and good acting and rebranded
it into whatever this is with all that
power comes responsibility Marnie you
stolen from spider-man if you want to
return to Halloweentown long enough you
start to notice that they really have no
regard for the character development in
the previous movies whatever though I
guess it doesn't matter because not even
a scene later she's leaving and her
mom's disapproval is never elaborated on
or resolved so apparently the whole
scene really was just a hopeless attempt
to remind us of the original imagined it
would be
citing ancient and magical who are you
talking to literally nobody is near you
this guy is the villain but you could
probably guess judging by the fire
behind him or the snakes and his
portrait oh and his last name is
sinister so I guess this movie is not
really into the whole subtlety thing
like don't get me wrong and obvious
villain can be just as a bit or better
than a plot plus one but I think we can
all agree this is overkill anyway
they're really excited to see Ryan
infirm high school musical but I haven't
watched Halloweentown high probably
since it came out I have no idea what
his deal is and I refuse to watch that
movie again unless I have to
oh how hard would have been not to start
tripping until your feet actually hit
the suitcase so next we're introduced to
what I guess you could call the plastics
of which University I'm pretty sure it's
just one girl copy and paste it three
times animal print skirts and all they
call them the sinister sisters yes
really do I even need to explain what
makes them so annoying didn't you read
the handbook we're mortal dumbbell we
might as well be GLIAC mortal why are
they so totally boring
dr. Grogg look right down you guys know
how I feel about cheesy Queen Bee
characters which is that I do not like
them and I feel like this spooky little
wix trio right here just goes to show
that this movie doesn't understand the
original at all
I mean Halloween town is unique family
adventure movie it's driven by its world
building and comedy and seem about
family bonds return to Halloweentown
is your average annoyingly predictable
Disney Channel original high school
movie complete with dumb cheesy dialogue
and that acting but this time they're
witches gag me anyway Dylan decides he
has a crush on one of them aquamarine
finds out that she's not allowed to use
magic on campus and then Dylan reveals
that he'll also be a student there I'm
almost positive that they're supposed to
have a decent AG app and this is her
freshman year so it's kind of a plot
hole but you know whatever it leads to
this hilariously awful conversation I'm
staying
that's funny because it just sounded
like you've heard your stance I'm a
student we're here that's funny because
it just sounded like you said here she
really did just say the exact same thing
twice I thought I had accidentally
skipped back or something but nope
that's the actual movie they did that I
don't think it was intentional either I
could be wrong and they could really
have put that in the script but for some
reason I feel like operon just mixed up
her lines and they kept it in I hope
that's true because it's even sadder to
think that somebody sat down and wrote a
screenplay like that on purpose no magic
in school this is how the ween town it's
supposed to be all magic all the time I
can't believe my mom something little
brother to babysit me again who are you
talking to you are alone in your room we
all talk to ourselves from time to time
but isn't it usually like a lowly
whisper or saying ouch when you stub
your toe please tell me people don't
just hold full conversations with
themselves like this anyway next Marni
evaporates into a lamp and makes friends
with a genie they go to lunch and she
runs into Ryan again the whole
interaction is really awkward and they
say a lot of
don't understand you two know each other
I just wanted to say I'm sorry you know
for everything apparently someone he
needs to clue me in on Halloweentown hi
because it's do not know what's going on
with these two there's a scene where the
lead sinister sister stills a book from
Mary's desk and then purses her lips
because she is evil the sentence for
sister's character traits can be boiled
down to bad fashion sense
permanently puckered lips and walking
together dramatically the movie just
really really doesn't want us to forget
that there you go
as if the fact that they do a bunch of
really mean things totally unprovoked
wasn't clear enough can't believe it
scarlet did that make her disappear
stop talking to yourself so I guess the
whole plot of this movie is that there's
a prophecy that Marni will find the gift
and I'm happy to report the child has
found the ancient box which contains the
gift which will somehow make a lot of
the school's staff powerful we
yeah I don't really get it either the
teachers in principal or Chancellor or
whatever they call it have this little
cult where they try to make the prophecy
come true it's really confusing actually
because the gift is essentially this
annual it that Marnie could control that
will allow her to make anybody do
exactly as she tells them so I don't get
why this gang of teachers think that
that would help them in any way it's all
pretty lame and cheesy you'll I be doing
my laundry are you spying on me no when
I was in college I did my laundry on
Wednesdays - I don't care how close a
mother and daughter are the fact that
you did laundry on Wednesdays does not
mean anything how would she come to this
conclusion honestly wouldn't it have
made more sense if she said something
about how Wednesday was laundry day at
home and that's how she guess can we
stop playing ourselves here anyway
aquamarine and Ryan's start to hit it
off I guess so they're the romance of
the movie great I totally cared about
that in this whole time
a lot of this movie is boring and I
don't want to explain it so we're just
gonna pretend it never happened
healthy appetite I like that girl can I
just say there is not a single other
cliched line of dialogue that I'm
periods me more than this one given the
choice would you rather have a rice cake
a Big Mac what does that matter well I
like a girl with a hearty appetite and
besides you just eliminated about 50% of
the girls for class I will never be able
to understand why it's a romantic trope
for the guy to comment on how much the
girl eats maybe it annoys me because I
know if the girl was fat they would not
be humming the same song or because
there has never been a scene where a
girl tells a guy she's a fan of his food
consumption but I hate this it's just
another backwards way for a guy to say
you're not like other girls
other girls being girls who diet in this
case if I went on a date with a guy and
he complimented how much or how little I
was eating I would not be going on a
second date because personally I'd
rather not have a human calorie counter
as a boyfriend thank you very much
anyway what's that ran out of the way is
now a good time to rant about how much
better the real Marnie is at playing
Marnie than aquamarine I don't have the
best eye for what is and isn't good
acting but there's a definite power
imbalance here I always thought Kimberly
Jenna brown like they don't want to be
in this movie but it turns out she has
had some scheduling conflicts honestly I
wish they would have postponed this
whole production for her if it was
absolutely impossible to get her they
should have just cancel it altogether
you know what even if they could get
hurt they should have cancelled it all
together I'm never very fond of
recasting even if I like the new actor
it's so distracting to me how am I
supposed to get invested in a story if I
can't stop thinking about the production
mishaps that led to a whole character
being recast like this isn't Marnie's
face you expect me to believe that this
is Marnie's face
no conduces again a lot of this movie is
boring and I don't want to explain that
so where's gonna pretend it never
happened
just truly sad when a few people force
their views on everyone else my mom says
that an inspirational quote to be passed
through the family tis really sad
honestly I'm happy for that line because
I think I'm gonna start saying that
I'm disappointed blah blah blah she goes
back in time villain turns into a dog
she finally comes to the conclusion that
all the obviously evil people are evil
sorry I really can't be bothered to get
into the details
should I I guess if you guys want to be
clued in on the intricacies of return to
Halloweentown but do you know anyway in
the end aquamarine pretends to be on the
villains side which is a very original
idea that's never been done before and
that's how she's able to get Dylan
turned back into a human
she also traps the gift in her friend's
lamp and destroys it or so we think
done done she actually sends it to a
library book for her brother to find
because that's the safest idea ever and
you totally can't tell there's something
iffy in that book surely nobody else
will find it in this public library this
is her sisters get their comeuppance and
all at once we get to weird minor plot
twists that don't even almost affect the
plot for one Ryan reveals that his
powers were stripped from something that
happened in the last movie go figure
so now he's just a mortal which means
that when he gave her flowers earlier in
the movie they didn't come out of thin
air and he learned a non magical magic
trick oh the betrayal and also one of
her professors is actually a spy yeah I
don't know why they didn't just leave
well enough alone
anyway that's it that's the movie it's
hard for me to even explain what makes
it worse than the original Halloweentown
but it sort of speaks for itself put any
given scene from each movie next to each
other and I don't think anybody could
tell you they prefer this one it's
almost hard to imagine them in the same
universe firstly because nobody believes
aquamarine is Marnie but also everything
else I mean the second to Halloweentown
movies are just so totally different
from the first two the first two are
quirky little family films with a lot of
heart and fun they can be totally cheesy
but it's a different kind of cheesy than
this they can be predictable but
exploring a whole new world of
Halloweentown
makes up for that when you constrict a
Halloweentown movie to one campus in
Halloweentown you're not doing yourself
any favors I couldn't tell the
difference between something like this
and Vampire Academy it's not a
Halloweentown movie as much as it's just
another forgettable Disney Channel
Original Movie it's probably mostly
about the acting and dialogue though and
considering a lot of the actors are the
same
that's probably mostly pacaya log it's
just really really crazy
nobody could deliver these lines well
man this family is so mushy doesn't like
my face so in conclusion Halloween
counts laughs and return to
Halloweentown like doesn't even lightly
press its fingers together and that's
that
[Music]
[Music]